tonight we're going to show you a candle
trick that you can use to impress your
date at your next candlelit dinner what
we're going to show you is how you can
light a candle without touching the weak
okay
so Nigel is going to light up a wooden
splint here I'm gonna blow out this
candle and then we're going to relight
the candle without touching the wick
ready I'm ready when you go one two
three you see that it's just that easy
maybe we should have a look at that in
slow motion so you can see that the
flame is actually traveling from the
splint back down to the wick so what's
going on there well what's happening is
that this trick is utilizing the states
of matter in the candle so most people
are familiar with the fact that a candle
is made of solid wax and when there's a
flame burning and there you can see
there's a pool of liquid wax but with
the flame burning around the liquid wax
we're actually getting a little wax
vapor and it's the wax vapor which is
actually burning not the wick exactly so
when we blow the flame at the weak there
is still that wets vapor hanging around
yeah we can rely quacks vapor above the
wick and you can watch that flame kind
of travel down through that wax vapor
back to the wick and relight the candle
exactly so as a final part of our trick
why don't we try to blow all 3 app-- and
relight them in one go yes then you can
use this to rekindle your rivets
we blew yeah worse